Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is doing something truly remarkable:
if we have a piece of audio of a real person
speaking, and a target video footage, it will
retime and change the video so that the target
person appears to be uttering these words.
Whoa!
This is different from what we've seen a few
episodes ago, where scientists at NVIDIA worked
on synthesizing lip sync geometry for digital
characters solely relying on audio footage.
The results were quite amazing, have
a look.
This was great for animating digital characters
when all we have is sound.
But this time around, we're interested in
reanimating the footage or real, existing
people.
A prerequisite to do this with a learning
algorithm is to have a ton of data to train
on - which we have in our possession as there
are many hours of footage of the former president
speaking during his weekly address.
This is done using a recurrent neural network.
Recurrent neural networks are learning algorithms
where the inputs and outputs can be sequences
of data.
So here, in the first part, the input can
be a piece of audio with the person saying
something, and it is able to synthesize the
appropriate mouth shapes and their evolution
over time to match the audio.
The next step is creating an actual mouth
texture from this rough shape that comes from
the learning algorithm, which is then used
as an input to the synthesizer.
Furthermore, the algorithm is also endowed
with an additional pose matching module to
make sure that the synthesized mouth texture
aligns with the posture of the head properly.
The final retiming step makes sure that the
head motions follow the speech correctly.
If you have any doubts whether this is required,
here are some results with and without the
retiming step.
You can see that this indeed substantially
enhances the realism of the final footage.
Even better, when combined with Google DeepMind's
WaveNet, given enough training data, we could
skip the audio footage altogether and just
write a piece of text, making Obama, or someone
else say what we've written.
There are also a ton of other details to be
worked out, for instance, there are cases
where the mouth moves before the person starts
to speak, which is to be taken into consideration.
The dreaded "umm"-s and "ahh"-s are classical
examples of that
There is also an important jaw correction
step and more.
This is a brilliant piece of work with many
non-trivial decisions that are described in
the paper - make sure to have a look at it
for details, as always, there is a link to
it is available the video description.
The results are also compared to the Face2face
paper from last year that we also covered
in the series.
It is absolutely insane to see this rate of
progress over the lapse of only one year.
If you have enjoyed this episode and you feel
that eight of these videos a month is worth
a dollar, please consider supporting us on
Patreon.
You can pick up some really cool perks there
and it is also a great deal of help for us
to make better videos for you in the future.
Earlier I also wrote a few words about the
changes we were able to make because of your
amazing support.
Details are available in the description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!